hi I'm Philip my man of the University
of Bridgeport my talk is on
computational religion
good afternoon my name is Philip my man
from the University of Bridgeport I know
you all are here to learn about God so
there's two layers to this talk one
we'll talk about God we'll figure out
the probability that God exists we'll do
machine learning on the tour all of that
but the meta purpose is I'll point out a
lot of so a lot of other talks go deep
this one is going to go broad and you'll
see lots of little tips and tricks of
doing weird little things as we go along
like Hebrew typesetting which Stephen
mentioned you can so Steve mentioned
there's computational X for everything
today X is religion Wikipedia data how
to use fine textual answer to be useful
careful things to do with Wolfram Alpha
and hidden assumptions how do you
semantic interpretation can we do any
probability of the new around stuff
that's in there how to delete stop words
in other languages words as musical
chords mail search sequence predict
alright let's get to it so let's start
with does God exist in Genesis 22 17
which everyone will be reading next week
is that as the Torah is the portion of
the Bible God tells Abraham you will
have so many descendants more than the
number of stars no no no even more than
the number of grains of sand if someone
says to you that do you think they think
there's more sand or more stars which
one sand right you you wouldn't say
you'll have you'll have hundreds of
descendents no dozens right it has to go
up right so God made a prediction a
prophecy that there's more grains of
sand than there are stars which seems
bizarre right because now that what
knowing what we know let me prove it to
you so oh there's this great function
I'm gonna use from Stack Exchange highly
Rutan she's here great function for
highlighting here's every translation
that I could find from this website of
this verse where he says stars in sand
you can see stars always comes before
sand it's not a mistranslation it's not
a you know a poetic justice stars always
comes first and we can plot it and it
always appears the string position of
stars always comes before sand in every
translation into English
let's compare it in the Hebrew in the
Hebrew this is a picture this top one is
a picture of what the verse says in
Hebrew and this bottom one is if you
just copy and paste the text so notice
something the first word has this -
right but that first word appears on the
left here and all of these words are
kind of backwards do you see that it's
it's a problem in fact if you look at
this the words and they are in order the
- is the first one and the second one
there the word ring is correct the
typesetting is wrong it makes sense
just the visual representation I wish to
even mention something they're working
well here's a little workaround if we
just split it by this the sentence isn't
and reverse it by the words now it looks
the way it should look right agreed now
we can highlight that and we see that
even in the Hebrew right Hebrew right to
left or red comes before blue so always
more sane than stars yeah which comes
first right that's all right but you
wouldn't say you wouldn't you wouldn't
think that they're saying is less right
if God is saying you're gonna have
thousands of descendants No - right
right it's yes it's additive it's more
usually it's a factor of ten times more
in typical Torah exaggerations right
it's usually a factor of ten or plus one
or something so we that's interesting
well how many stars are there anyone
know we could start off by thinking well
from ancient times what did people think
how many stars there were and I'm
Wikipedia you have a great you can use
Wikipedia data get some text sentences
see the timeline of history so around
1800 BC that's the earliest star charts
we know there were about seventeen or
eighteen constellations from the
Babylonian star charts which by the way
do you know why we have 360 degrees
Babylonian star charts eventually they
solidified from seventeen or eighteen
down to twelve each one had thirty
degrees that gives us 360 degrees and
those are the twelve zodiac signs that
we have through to today in the Beijing
in the don't want star chart of this is
705 this is well past any estimate of
when the Bible was written right there's
a 700 you
after the modern era this is a beautiful
star chart that was drawn at that time
and if you do find textual answer here's
another little clue I want to search
Wikipedia data for the Ptolemies star
catalog and for the don't along to star
chart for how many stars there are right
that's what I'm searching for how many
stars and it's automatically figuring
out the answer well in Ptolemy it's fine
it's in the Wikipedia text and they'll
say there's about a thousand stars but
if you want to search the dun Hong star
chart it's unfortunately in a caption of
the image so the tip there is don't just
use the particle plain text that use the
entire raw article wiki code and haven't
find the textual answer from there and
so it'll find it so whether it was
ptolemy which was when ptolemy was
around of 140 or don't wanna round 705
they only knew about a thousand stars
right so how many didn't know earlier
only about a thousand well suppose
someone was a really good astronomer how
many could they have seen thousands of
years ago
well Wolfram Alpha says the number of
stars visible to naked eyes about nine
thousand did you know that if you look
in the Stars you actually try to count
if you can't get to millions and
billions and trillions right without a
telescope so what is the that's what
they could have seen how many are there
in fact well let's just ask Wolfram
Alpha there's 10 to the 24th stars the
end where does that come from it comes
from how many stars are in a typical
galaxy if you search that lets say
between 200 and 400 billion and I used
to think and maybe you still did too
that the two numbers you only need to
know for astronomers is about 100
billion stars in the galaxy in about 100
billion galaxies you multiply them and
you get some number but it turns out in
the past few years the number of
galaxies has increased and we now have
two trillion we know that there are two
trillion galaxies so if we take by the
way semantic interpretation is a nice
function because it doesn't need to go
to the cloud it just computes it
directly and use how to convert two
trillion 210-212 but here's the thing
those two trillion galaxies the research
was done by this fellow named Khan Solis
if we do fine textual answer from an
article published on live science about
it and ask how many stars are in an
average galaxy we don't get two to four
hundred billion we get a hundred million
twice right
twice it says a hundred million not a
hundred billion what I was sure it was a
hundred billion the mistake I made is
the same mistake Wolfram Alpha made
check this out when you click on how
many stars in a typical galaxy it
actually interprets as the number of
stars in the Milky Way galaxy our galaxy
and it turns out our galaxy is not
typical we're a pretty large galaxy
congratulations most of these new
galaxies that they've been discovering
and that make bringing visit to two
trillion they're older galaxies that had
fewer stars
the average galaxy now only has about a
hundred million all right so if we take
these two interpretations the on either
from a hundred million galaxies on a
million stars per galaxy times two
trillion galaxies or at the high end a
hundred billion stars per galaxy times
two trillion galaxies then we get that
the number of stars is somewhere between
10 to the 20th and 10 to the 23rd make
sense so it's a range all right I know
what you're thinking if we're gonna do
the same process for grains of sand
you're gonna lose your mind we're not
don't worry Wolfram Alpha tells you
exactly how many grains of sand there
are and you can expand it it's correct
it knows it's earth not Mars everything
is perfect so boom sand is easy sand
there is this amount so number of sand
is a is somewhere between 10 to the 20th
and 10 to the 24 so there are two
numbers we have they're both in the same
range isn't that interesting by itself
then the 20 is in the 23rd can you
imagine three thousand two thousand
whenever it was years ago writing a
prophecy that predicts that even that
they're even close because you can see
maybe a few hundred a few thousand maybe
stars but you can tell there's a
quintillion bazillion brazilian grains
of sand right like you wouldn't say you
can't you wouldn't exaggerate to the
effect of you know i love you from here
to here no from here to way were way
over there right that doesn't make any
sense it's too much of an exaggeration
right stars in sand so the first thing
is that they're relatively comparable to
within about an order of magnitude which
is amazing well so which one is better
which one is that which one is the truth
larger the the way to answer this
question I think is we have to
effectively confidence intervals for
them so if the 95% cotton
let's plus or minus 2 Sigma so we can
just do divide the that take the mean
and divide divide the range by 4 that's
4 Sigma we can try it first of all this
new around function in in the version 12
but maybe your luck will be better than
mine in probability doesn't seem to work
for it
so even though it knows what an around
is you can't quite tell what the
probability is but no problem we could
just tell each the number of the grains
of sand is between those two conferences
and the stars are you ready to find out
the answer the probability that God
exists that prophecy is for real ready
I'll scroll up so you can all see the
the big reveal 89% 89 percent chance God
is real now we can make a little website
for people to change because it's very
sensitive to what you expect your
estimates to be about thus the number of
stars in sand the key thing about this
is the data bin so it's really easy to
create a new data bin and have
everybody's answers show up afterwards
so here's God probability let's change
the low estimate to 21 or something
submit and it'll tell you you are God
and you're welcome to visit this page
too it'll tell you your probability
right here the orange dot and everybody
else's was ever voted and the average so
on average which is only been me so far
you're welcome to change it has has been
about 73 percent I used to have an error
I used to think that because of the
billion trillion whatever issue I
thought that there was only a 2% chance
of God existing I was very depressed but
fortunately everything worked out
alright let's look some visualizations
for in Hebrew so this so have a books
this is you can see the characters are
in Hebrew very sheet bar and so on
this is from the Leningrad codex which
is a thousand year old oldest complete
manuscript of the Hebrew Torah it has
three hundred four thousand eight
hundred fifty characters if you ask
Wikipedia how many letters are in the
modern tour they say three hundred four
8:05
I swear maybe ten times I saw these two
numbers I thought they were the same
there's a difference the difference is
about one basis point
1% of 1% which is de minimis and there
are some differences but the differences
are something like you know vowel placed
here there that no like evolve or
something ok so one problem with word
clouds what clouds are great but what's
the most commonly occurring word in
every single one the first four books
and one of the ones what's that first
word the biggest word you know the word
what is it oh you see I share but what
about these these ones at what's at
exactly it's like nothing right it's
almost like it it's some kind of pronoun
or something it's a stop word but
there's no English there's no Hebrew
delete stop words so but we can create
it how let's take all the stopped words
out of the word list so what are we left
with non stop words take the compliment
boom we have the all the stop words the
Wolfram language use because it's not in
the documentation anywhere you don't
know what the list of stop words are but
now we know where oh really okay we
should put that in here somewhere no not
here not there but this is where it
belongs right okay I believe you I
believe you but there's still no way to
translate it right so we can translate
it here we'll just translate word by
word into all three possible Hebrew
things put them all together now we have
Hebrew stop words and boom it takes a
little at the calculate so I'll just
show you what happens it gets rid of all
the ads and everything else great now
that looks much nicer all right
so we we watched the Torah let's listen
to the Torah so every week around the
world everybody who reads the Torah
reads the same parsha the same Torah
portion this is the Torah portion for
this week we're gonna play it it takes
15 seconds to play it each word is a
chord right each letter has a sound and
all each word is a chord so we're gonna
put them all together the only you can
listen to the whole Torah this way and
it's kind of interesting to hear the
differences between the books but here
the only thing I think you'll really
here is seat or
and the words become shorter so the
chords will play a little faster so
let's see if how that works
not very well I don't know how standard
there's no way to turn the volume for me
right anyway the all I did was take the
character code and subtract the middle
character code of 1501 I think that's
what it was
yeah 1501 so then it just goes on a C
scale sorry we can hear you do this so
you won't see it but you'll hear it here
we go can you hear that
but something's my computer parently all
right apologies
I'll sing it to you later okay so let's
do machine learning on the so here's the
goal is to generate use the original
tour to generate new verses from the
tour and see if it can fool people
so we'll do teacher forcing which is the
same as the docs but just like a couple
more options we'll add in here's the the
source documents we have the the name of
the book the chapter and verse in the
text so we could put the tour all
together i here's some random samples of
the way the machine learning will take
the inputs now i don't know how you guys
do neural net training but the way my
mom told me to do it is you always start
with a small one first so you just start
with like a sixty second training which
is nothing there's no results but now
you have the basics and then every time
you you train you just put on a loop to
train cuz the problem is your computer
will break right you've traded for 48
hours and then it broke and you lost
everything because you forgot to save it
so make a loop save it every whatever
some number of hours I used to do it
every hour which is great during the day
because you know you need to check your
phone every hour but at night and you
wake up you have like 20 messages it's
annoying so do it every four hours if
you do every four hours
you can send yourself a mail message
with the with the results and then
afterwards you can just collect those
results with them with the new mail
server and mail search so here's all of
those messages I sent myself and once
you get that in the data set you just
read rejigger them and you have all the
results so this is after four hours this
is the lowest validation error and the
final validation Erin here's what it
says so here's a sample from it and
Hashem said I know that Hashem the
Israel after Thayer Forte's ah that's it
that's frustrating right and you keep
going down and after a while it seems
like it's a little bit better but then
you still defiled it's not a word I got
swears and some of them I clean those up
some of them are just anachronistic like
Hashem spoken to Moses and unto Aaron
this after 92 hours and she barand I
don't even know what that is but
whatever she you don't want to get
burned by a female God
and Hashem speaks to Moses and unto
Aaron that's fine but then Joseph where
did he come from
they never appear in the same verse so
the problem is after a hundred hours I
didn't get much improvement at all that
we're still having things like wait X ye
rain it looks like it's programming
let's see if we can get some better
results one thing I was thinking is well
there's new functions and the typical
what is the typical way of working with
Wolfram language over several years
right what happens as things evolve you
work on a project for years and years
and years you have a huge codebase that
does something really remarkable and the
next version comes out with a one-line
solution right it's wonderful but also
sad
so sequence predict is a great function
you just feed it the entire Torah it
thinks for 40 seconds that's it and boom
it's done and then when you predict from
it it's not as good isn't it on there
but it's really fast and it's useful for
some other things I'll show you if you
just do random next elements it's it's
equally garbagey right it's it's not
very good the other thing you could do
is the next sequence what's the
difference random next element is every
single time it'll create a new element
new element new element totally random
like a random sample next sequence it
creates more like Monte Carlo right it's
going out for lots of different
sequences and seeing which one of them
total has the highest probability does
that make sense
the whole thing together not just one at
a time and that you often unless you
change the temperature you end up just a
loop right Hashem spoke saying speak
saying speak speak speak speak saying
speak but this got me thinking that the
right solution is something like
reducing the small probabilities of
things that happen so we can generate a
sample generate this from scratch two
things here one we can generate a sample
of
of the information that's coming in
given whatever you want to start with
but only with top probabilities so
there's this parameter of top
probabilities that you could take as a
property if you just think random sample
it takes all probabilities wouldn't it
be nice to have a top random sample just
like you have a top probabilities well
so that's all this does is takes a top
random sample so you feed it with
anything you want like if you just start
with and then he'll think for a bit and
say so okay that's useful
ever after different that looks pretty
good but you can also ask questions like
and at the old from technology
conference and it'll feed it now imagine
you had this you know there's a
Microsoft Word or Google Doc plugin it
break read all of the stuff you've
written so far and just suggests entire
paragraphs that you can Jenna had
wouldn't that be nice
before all with the base of these now
that doesn't make any sense so you can
just delete it append some new ones and
then against thee from Hashem taiga
that's a pretty good one and thou shalt
put on varying it so then you could just
delete the rest right so you can have a
combination of slightly human editing
with automatic additions and thought
you'll keep it and say unto them when
you became one yeah it's not bad
thus shall you stand by the camp the
camp of Wolfram very good so let's do a
survey I'm going to generate all of
these things make a bin one of the
things I did so I spent whatever almost
three hours generating both random
samples and new generated samples got
10,000 samples of those but also the
next thing you can do is classify those
samples I know some of them came from
the original tour and some of them were
machine generated right so I can feed
that into a class of fire and the
classifier does a really good job it
says these are obvious and these are
confusing so let's just look at the
confusing ones maybe that'll be even
more confusing to human people here's
for an example this is the correct
classification and this is what the
prediction was so it's it's not from the
Torah but the classifier thought it was
because in its Hashem spoke unto Moses
saying the Cana named the hittite and
the perizzite in the Canaan and the
Egyptians
it sounds real right totally made-up
okay here's a let's do a quick one and
then open the question so here's the
survey this is 10 out of the 10,000
questions and you raise your hand if you
think it's from the Bible
and he took us up his parable and said
from a ROM Belloc bringeth definitely
wrong right oh we've made me that the
king of Moab from the mountains of the
east come curse me Jacob and come
execrate Israel probably not right let's
go probably now and the burnt offerings
were strangers which again thought I
said whatever so the tabernacle 'thou
hast was not seeing the basket what do
you think no right it doesn't have a
certain it doesn't have a certain like
consistency right perfect so it's a
factual error stupid machine learning
and that sham said unto Moses if I may
prolong your days upon land which I
swore into the further thought that
sounds good right yes any disagreement
all right oh one thing just to point out
when you're doing this isn't asked asks
within an ask function if you're doing a
random survey and you need to remember
some random number you have to put an
ask display after your first ask
assignment of the random number
otherwise it'll never update that's data
thing and it'll get generate new random
numbers it's little bug not in that bug
it's just it's a weirdness of the way
you use it and when any man might make
the waters upon the tent of meeting and
come forth out of Egyptian law I think
what do you think yes seems reasonable
right at least there's a logical
coherence the entire sentence right
Israel hallow on to shem having his
clean unclean at that fashion no right
for it is no vain thing for you because
it is your life and through this thing
he shall prolong your days upon the land
whether you go over the Jordan to
possess it who says yes who says no oh
that's a yes okay and Hashem spoken to
Moses saying speak into the congregation
saying get you up from about the
dwelling of Korah Dathan and abiram who
says yes he says no okay that's a yes
and Hashem spoke unto Moses saying take
it upon his house and he called the name
of it the children of Israel yes okay
alright two more just shouted out what
you thinking I will bring the land into
desolation and your enemies that dwell
therein will be astonished at it
oh that's confusing who says yes who
says no oh it's that's a close call I'll
say yes astonished is a funny
translation and they made their land and
saw that he touches the Mount and the
names of the sons of Joseph from the
land of Canaan they come who says yes
says no majority seems to be no all
right let's see what our results are oh
we only got five out of ten right that's
not good
wow that's crazy we thought okay so I
share if I prolong it where's that
activate Warner was astonished well it
wasn't the Bible the astonished one
wasn't the Bible a good job okay
questions thank you thank you yes oh
thank you so much I was very
disappointed with machine learning so
machine learning seems to very quickly
give interesting results
but then it tapers off and it and it
loses a lot of the magic and logical
coherence of human speech so I was
hoping that maybe maybe I'm miss trained
and maybe I need to train it more maybe
the combination of training and
reclassifying will work I don't know
yeah please
I don't have a GPU yeah yes that's it
that's a great point actually I did I
trained this in the cloud with the GPU
of GPU yeah yeah it's it's the same one
from the docs teacher forcing yes just
tell me where to go I'll be there any
other questions
all right Brook a Shem thank you very
much
[Applause]